she reflections are more feared than
greyscale and far past the point of
reason a legend calls it Prince Garen's
curse after an ancient Eastern prince
whom the Valyrians hung in a cage and
forced to watch the emulation of his
city and people as his city burned under
dragon flame this Prince called on his
God for vengeance and a thick fog of
foul humors rose from the Rhoyne to
smother the Valyrians with greyscale but
if diseases could be caught down by the
vengeful we'd have no health in the
world more likely the disease predates
the Valerians entirely confined to some
remote region of Essos and only spread
throughout the world
once the Valyrians linked the continent
with robes and Dragons the disease
begins as a rash the afflicted flesh
stiffens calcifies and cracks and
assumes the disease's nominal hue
victims are graciously spared pain as
the disease dull sensation in the
infected limbs but the disease is
insidious and slowly it creeps over the
skin and into the organs once the
infection reaches the brain feral
madness replaces humanity and the
transformation to a stone man is
complete there is no consensus on
treatment some masters advocate of
mustard poultice is vinegar rinses and
scalding hot baths others claim only
three cures axe sword and cleaver
hacking off afflicted parts does
sometimes stop the spread of the disease
but not always many a man has sacrificed
an arm or foot only to find the other
going gray those who have been
miraculously cured of greyscale a few
and usually were subjected to so many
treatments that isolating the
responsible cure is impossible besides
few maesters priests or healers have the
courage for such experiments as would
prove a cure greyscale is highly
contagious being known to spread from
even the slightest contact with an
infected person hence the current
occupation of Valyria by the stone men
exiled from their homelands at the first
sign of the disease what they do there
with their final months or even years
for greyscale is a slow killer no one
knows no one wants to find out